alors dévié d'un horizon prédéfinis on
pourrait pour ça imaginez que la vie est
une expédition en kayak
quand j'ai mis un visuel pour ceux qui
n'aiment pas trop imaginer un vous la
vie voyais un peu l'idée alors
effectivement comme ça mais le voyage a
l'air plutôt sympa
et pourtant ce tell tale voyage n'est
pas toujours sans risque
l'eau est froide on peut se cogner
contre un rocher des rapides font peur
et quand un orage éclate le courant
s'intensifie de dangereuses laventure
peut même parfois s'avérer mortelle au
milieu des années trente un ouragan
dénommé nazisme s'est abattue sur la
rivière de la vie déjà bien agité par la
première guerre mondiale et la crise de
il provoqua le pire déluge que
l'humanité ait jamais connu en 1945 le
bilan est effroyable
quarante mille morts et un monde en
ruines on peut aisément comprendre que
les survivants traumatisés par toutes
ces années d'horreur et eu quelques
réticences à l'idée de poursuivre cette
expédition
demandez à quelqu'un qui vient de
survivre par miracle aux chutes du
niagara de remonter dans son kayak
il est probable qu'il vous faudra
attaquer sur la tronche à l'image des
castors et zur donc l'idée de construire
un barrage sur la rivière afin de vivre
sur un grand lac à l'abri des courants
et des rapides
en deux mots en sécurité et en paix
c'est ainsi que les états occidentaux
créèrent de grands systèmes de
solidarité collective afin de garantir à
jacques un moyen de subsistance quels
que soient les aléas de la vie
en france la sécurité sociale les
caisses de retraite l'assurance chômage
ou encore le smic
des bouées flottantes furent installés
aussi sur ce lac afin de délimiter les
espaces pour que chacun puisse jouir en
toute quiétude un endroit bien à lui
évidemment la taille des parcelles
dépendez du salaire qu'on gagnait alors
évidemment la recette une vie réussie à
l'époque pardon à la recette une vie
réussie à l'époque était très clair et
le chemin tout tracé
première étape trouver un emploi qui
permet de se procurer une parcelle est
de garantir ses revenus jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie en période de plein emploi
pendant les trente glorieuses la chose
était relativement simple à réaliser
deuxième étape fonder une famille qui
serait forcément heureuse puisqu'elle
jouirait du confort est à sécurité de la
parcelle
et enfin troisième et dernière étape
pouvoir ressentir une certaine forme de
fierté et d'accomplissement personnel de
réussir à préserver et à agrandir cette
parcelle tout au long de sa vie en fait
cette recette vous l'avez peut-être
reconnu
c'est la fameuse grosso modo à la
fameuse pyramide de maslow ce
psychologue américain qui s'est fait
mondialement connaître après la guerre
pour avoir modéliser cette recette du
bonheur
né en 1961 en fait j'ai été élevé dans
cette logique du barrage dès mon enfance
mon parcours de vie était donc
totalement tracé lui devait bien
travailler à l'école pour trouver pour
refondre repos pour trouver un emploi
qui me permettrait de gagner l'argent
dont j'aurai besoin pour être heureux
pas toujours facile de comprendre tous
les enjeux d'une vie d'adulte quand on a
10 ans ma mère mais elle avait donc
expliquer de manière beaucoup plus
simple si tu n'as pas un beau bulletin à
la fin de ton trimestre baisser tout le
récent et avic tu fout en l'air
déjà qu'on m'avait dit que dieu m'en
vais en enfer s'il n'était pas sage ça
ne donnait pas vraiment envie de grandir
mais bon ayant été levée à l'ombre de
cette pyramide
je me suis plié à cette règle qui a
quand même bien fonctionné pour moi
puisque à la fin de mes études j'ai eu
la possibilité j'étais être engagée par
un homme d'affaires suisse qui cherchait
quelqu'un pour créer une compagnie
aérienne au départ de liège
c'est comme ça que je me suis retrouvé
en 1987 à 26 ans directeur général d'air
excellent très beau salaire magnifique
voiture de fonction voyages gratuits en
première classe dans le monde entier et
un petit regarde envie de la part de
certains de mes camarades de promo le
pied quoi je mettais directement
installé dans une magnifique parcelles
comme quoi cette recette dont on m'avait
parlé fonctionné à merveille la preuve
en suivant ce système
j'avais déjà construit le premier étage
de la pyramide
esi simple je me sentais tellement
puissant
mais pas heureux
sam interpellerait je me sentais trahi
par les principes avec lesquels j'avais
grandi on m'avait promis que je serai
heureux si j'aime constituer une belle
parcelle et là je commençais ma part et
de ma carrière à un poste où plein de
genre et devrait terminer la leur et ça
ne fonctionnait pas pour moi qu'est ce
qu'il me fallait de plus probablement
une parcelle encore plus grande
et puis au bout de quelques années bout
de deux ans à peu près une conversation
anodine avec l'ami d'une de mes soeurs
me donne un premier début de réponse et
in avait 40 ans et venait de vendre sa
société il avait une gagne énormément
d'argent à la fin des repas des
anniversaires on s'est retrouvés tous
les deux sur la terrasse et là je lui ai
demandé etienne tu dois vraiment être
très heureux maintenant
et il m'a répondu non bien sûr suite
en avoir gagné beaucoup d'argent je
viens de divorce et j'ai une petite
fille de deux ans je ne la voit pas très
souvent
et elle me manque
en quelques mots etienne venait de me
prouver qu'un cliché pouvait être vrai
car oui l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
alors et pour ceux qui en doutent encore
en fait il existe une multitude de quasi
scientifique qu'il prouve
parmi ces deux personnalités l'une
possède beaucoup plus d'argent que
l'autre est ce que vous seriez capable
de dire laquelle
alors bien sûr ça le vide évidemment pas
dire que c'est la pauvreté qui rend
heureux
ni que la richesse rend systématiquement
systématiquement malheureux un ce serait
totalement absurde dans notre société un
minimum de ressources est indispensable
et l'argent et toute la halle le biais
les bienfaits qui lui qui procure et
toute la liberté d'action qu'il procure
contribue évidemment largement à notre
bien-être c'est une évidence mais on
peut décemment dire que l'argent n'est
pas la source du vrai bonheur quand on
sait qu'en ce suscite cinq fois plus en
suisse qu'au kenya parce que comme
etienne venait de l'apprendre à ses
dépens et comme j'étais en train de
passer à côté en me focalisant sur
l'agrandissement de ma parcelle il
existe une valeur plus importante que la
réussite financière pour être heureux
c'est la qualité de la relation qu'on a
avec les autres
en fait ce qui rend heureux mais c'est
l'amour qu'on partage en famille c'est
la chaleur d'une amitié profonde c'est
la joie d'avoir aidé quelqu'un en
difficulté car entre eux bien plus qu'un
compte en banque bien fourni et c'est là
où j'ai commencé à me demander s'il va
pas comme un petit problème de
conception dans la pyramide de maslow et
sam été confirmé quelques temps plus
tard en janvier 91
saddam hussein a envahi le koweït en
provoquant la première crise du golfe en
même temps qu'une énorme crise dans le
transport aérien
un peu comparable à celle qu'on connaît
maintenant et rexel n'a pas pu surmonter
cette crise et j'ai été contraint de
déposer le bilan en janvier 92 de paix
et avec un emploi du temps surbooké je
me suis retrouvé au chômage le choc fut
rude 30 ans célibataire sans emploi
belge tableau n'était pas vraiment
idyllique mais à quelque chose malheur
est parfois bon parce que ces étapes de
ma vie m'a permis de prendre conscience
qu'il existe une relation encore plus
importante que la relation qu'on a avec
les autres pour être heureux c'est la
relation qu'on entretient avec soi même
ce qui rend véritablement heureux c'est
la qualité du rapport bienveillant que
l'on entretient avec soin et donc en
matière de construction de pyramide
mince l'eau n'était peut-être pas khéops
en même temps cette pyramide tient elle
est peut-être un peu bizarre mais lui
tient elle a même plutôt bien tenu
pendant les trente glorieuses mais elle
ne tient qu'à la condition que la
réussite financière soit garanti parce
que quand j'ai perdu mon emploi
c'est toute la pyramide qui s'est
écroulé je perde
plus qu'un salaire c'est toute ma vie
qui s'écroulait parce que comme la
moitié de mes relations problème mon
environnement professionnel je pouvais
rayé d'un seul coup la moitié de mon
carnet d'adressés et en ce qui concerne
l'autre moitié que je n'avais plus
contacter toutes occupées que j'étais à
agrandir ma parcelle il avait changé
numéro il m'a été tellement identifié à
mon poste de pdg que j'en étais venu à
évaluer ma valeur personnel
proportionnelle à mon salaire et là tout
d'un coup comme je ne gagnais plus rien
ben je ne valait plus rien et à mes yeux
je n'étais plus rien
c'est bête hein mais quand on a ces
troubles
r on sent pas vraiment mieux de sa forme
heureusement au bout d'un certain temps
j'ai commencé à voir les choses
autrement je me suis rendu compte que
ressasser le passé ne faisait que
prolonger ma douleur et j'ai changé mon
questionnement intérieur
plutôt que de me dire pourquoi ça
m'arrive à moi
demandée et pourquoi ça m'arriverait pas
à moins au nom de quel principe par quel
miracle je répare est épargné de toutes
les preuves dans la vie même le fils
d'un type pourtant très très haut placée
a fini sur une croix
alors ça m'a l'air de rien mais changer
ce questionnement intérieur été le début
d'une véritable révolution personnelle
parce que l'évidence m'a enfin sauté aux
yeux
plutôt que de rechercher à construire ma
pyramide à l'identique comme je l avais
toujours un prix je pouvais tout aussi
bien la construire à l'endroit elle
serait beaucoup plus solide construit
les choses dans le bon ordre ça change
tout cheops l'avez compris bien avant
ikea alors
rires 2 0 et on va commencer par le
commencement
voilà bon sauf que ce qui vient nous
prendre deux secondes maintenant prend
réalité un petit peu plus de temps dans
la vraie vie parce qu entretenir un
rapport bienveillant avec soin de ce
fait malheureusement pas en un jour
on en est pas toujours conscients et
pour prendre compte pour se rendre
compte de l'ampleur de la tâche
il ya un petit est très simple qu'on
peut tous effectués quand vous avez
quelques minutes passées dans votre
salle de bain et puis là vous vous
regardez dans le miroir pendant quelques
secondes vraiment hâte en s'aimant vous
souriez même
et puis à haute voix vous prononcer
votre prénom et vous dites je t'aime ça
fait bizarre
et vous savez que vous allez djenné
parce qu'on connaît déjà tous la
réaction spontanée de notre petite voix
intérieure
mais qu'est ce qui t'arrive pour qui tu
te prends tu t'es vu t'as vu ta tête
avec d'abord des problèmes et puis on en
reparle
c'est dingue on est très très loin du
rapport bienveillant envers soi même
l'être humain doit être la seule espèce
y critique au monde envers elle même est
ce qu'on peut imaginer cannois qu'un
oiseau migrateur se met à douter de son
sens de l'orientation qu'un poirier pas
son existence a regretté de ne pas être
un pommier ou bien qu'un bout veuille se
venir se mettre sur ma tête c'est
absurde mais quand tous nos âmes ravagé
durant toute notre enfance qu'on était
bête maladroit égoïste ou paresseux
quand on a souligné à gros traits rouges
toutes nos erreurs et nos distractions
il n'est pas étonnant qu'une petite voix
toxiques et finit par s'installer en
nous et qu'on ait perdu un peu confiance
en nos moyens
qu'arriverait-il un oiseau migrateur si
c'est un pardon un oisillon tout frais
sorti du nid si ses parents lui disait
qu'il était trop nul pour voler il ne
prendrait jamais son envol en fait être
bienveillant avec soin ses remplacer
cette voie de souk sic par un dialogue
constructif et porter
fais de mon mieux j'apprends de mes
erreurs je suis capable
j'ai toute ma place dans ce monde je
suis digne d'amour
très important c'est la pas facile à
dire de tous vous allez voir entraînez
vous vous allez voir les réactions
qu'ils allaient avoir débarrassé ses
doigts toxiques
on retrouve une sécurité intérieure et
on dégage alors une toute nouvelle
énergie
et puis
oc l'opposé mais le reste est évidemment
beaucoup plus facile à construire
on sait tous que pour être bien avec
avec les autres il faut être bien avec
soi c'est évident ne dit on pas
d'ailleurs d'une personne bien dans sa
peau qu'elle rayonne et comme le soleil
c'est la chaleur humaine dégagés par
cette sécurité intérieure qui donne aux
autres l'envié de se rapprocher d'elle
et le plaisir de la côtoyer
c'est exactement pour la même raison que
la côte d'azur accueille 13 millions de
touristes par an alors que la picardie
13 dont 11 belge déjà très heureux
d'être arrivé dans le sud
alors quand au dernier bloc
s'il ne faut évidemment pas sous-estimer
son importance
l'idée n'est évidemment pas de l'oublier
il garde toute son importance en
remettant l'argent au sommet de la
pyramide il retrouve une plus juste
place tout simplement il n'est plus le
but
la base de tout ce que l'on fait et nous
nous aveugle plus il devient juste une
conséquence agréable indispensable même
mais juste une conséquence d'une
activité effectuée en fonction de ses
propres valeurs et de ceux qui on est
vraiment et ça change tout
alors vu comme ça l est pas plus belle
notre pyramide quand même un évidemment
ça ne résoudra pas tous les problèmes
ça nous préservera pas de tout accident
de la vie une chute de revenus
un licenciement une séparation la perte
d'un proche
une maladie mais quoi qu'il en soit
c'est quand le socle de la pyramide est
bien ancré dans le sol qu'on sera de
toute façon le mieux armé pour traverser
toutes ces périodes plus difficiles
en tout cas je sais avec le recul qu'à
la fin des rexel ça m'aurait bien aimé
bien aidé pardon d'avoir ma pyramide un
petit peu plus à l'endroit et je pense
aujourd'hui que c'est très important et
je sais que je ne suis pas le seul dans
ce cas là parce que depuis la fin des
trente glorieuses et du plein emploi la
sécurité financière n'est plus garanti à
personne à l'argent est à l'envers on va
le remettre à l'endroit parce qu'il est
important d'argent hommes depuis la fin
des trente glorieuses je me disais et du
plein emploi
mais la réussite financière n'est plus
garanti à personne depuis 73 et le choc
pétrolier
des crises successives n'ont cessé
d'ouvrir deux d'énormes brèches dans le
barrage aujourd'hui l'eau s'échappe bien
pluie qu'elle n'y entre le niveau du lac
est en train de baisser
il ya de plus en plus de monde sur une
surface qui se rétrécit
les plats sont donc de plus en plus cher
et les exclus de plus en plus nombreux
alors au brésil mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec ça parce qu'en plus même pour
les gens qui vivent dans des parcelles
sécuriser la vie n'est plus du tout ce
qu'elle était ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à ne plus trouver de sens ne
plus trouver un sens à leur vie
en fait ils deviennent de plus en plus
comme c'est ce jeune ouvrier qui
expliquait en 768 lors des manifs depuis
trente-six je me bats pour des
revendications de salaire avant moi mon
père s'est battu pour des revendications
de salaire aujourd'hui j'ai la télé une
volkswagen et un frigo au social au
total je n'ai jamais cessé d'avoir une
vie de con
quand on se rend compte que sa vie ne se
résume finalement qu'à tourner en rond
dans sa parcelle comme un poisson dans
son bocal le réveil peut être un peu
brutal alors oui avec tout ça qu'est ce
qu'on fait ensign a dit qu'un problème
ne pouvait pas être résolue tant qu'on
reste dans la même logique que celle qui
avait engendré ce problème
si on suit son raisonnement et on en a
suivi de plus bête ça veut donc dire que
pour sortir de la logique du barrage il
faut aujourd'hui que pour trouver de
nouvelles solutions par exemple pardon
il faut aujourd'hui sortir de cette
logique du barrage en fait comme pour
résoudre le célèbre problème des neuf
points à relier en quatre lignes droites
il faut sortir du cadre
c'est ce problème ou bien comme pour
résoudre le problème du raid du
villageois pourchassé par deux
rhinocéros en colère il faut prendre de
la hauteur ce qui nous permet alors de
constater que l'eau qui s'échappe du
barrage ne s'évapore pas elle continue
le plus naturellement du monde sa route
dans la rivière en contrebas
ce qui veut dire qu'il existe une vie au
delà du barrage et donc que pour ceux à
qui cette logique des trente glorieuses
ne convient plus il n'y a eu ni su
quitter ce lac des trente glorieuses
devenu inhospitalier pour rejoindre la
rivière et partir à l'aventuré
comment est ce qu'on fait ça donc
le voir en remettant tout simplement sa
pyramide en l'endroit vous allez voir
avec le socle de la relation à soi avec
la relation à soi comme socle pardon on
voit les choses de manière tout à fait
différente aux noces on crée on imagine
on se fait confiance pour aller au bout
de ses rêves en sortant de sa zone de
confort
alors bien sûr se retrouver en eau vive
dans le kayak est un petit peu bizarre
au début on veut boire quelques tasses
mais on s'y fait très vite et très
rapidement on y trouve un plaisir
immense car tous les cas qu'ils se le
dire on la rivière est bien plus
accueillante que l'imaginent avant d'y
entrer
en fait c'est l'exact opposé d'une
brasserie parisienne
quand elles sont ouvertes d'ailleurs
très chouette quelle route et un jour
mais ça nous évitera non plus évidemment
la rivière n'est pas toujours un long
fleuve tranquille
à certains moments on sera
inévitablement entraîner dans direct
dans des directions qu'on n'avait pas
imaginé
il faudra leur s'adapter se relever et
changer de trajectoire parfois
c'est ni bien ni mal c'est juste la vie
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est essentiel
d'être dans la rivière parce que vu
l'état de la planète il est essentiel de
réagir et de se mettre à penser de
manière différente aujourd'hui
notre planète est très endommagée en
fait la génération des 30 glorieuses
avait cru pouvoir dompter la nature
avec le recul on se rend compte qu'elle
a plutôt aussi fini par un saccage et
les océans sont couverts de plastique
les seules et les sous-sols s'épuise
l'air devient irrespirable le climat se
dérègle et des centaines d'espèces
disparaissent chaque année
en fait notre monde ressemble
aujourd'hui à une énorme discothèque où
on rallume la lumière au bout de la nuit
les canapés sont défoncés les murs sont
sales
le sol jonché détritus et l'odeur
nauséabonde nauséabonde
sans parler de l'inconnu avec qui on a
dansé toute la nuit et qu'on découvre en
pleine lumière
alors aujourd'hui on a le choix bien on
peut éteindre les néons de remettre la
musique à fond et continuer de danser en
imaginant et en espérant avoir grimpé de
temps devant soi avant que la cnsa
complément elle sait qu on peut
s'abrutir dans l'alcool en essayant de
se convaincre que tout finira par
s'arranger comme l'espéraient les
habitants de pompéi le soir en venant
laisse coucher ou bien on sort de cette
boîte de nuit
on respire un grand coup on prend son
kayak et ont rejoint la rivière
mais la tendance est là aujourd'hui les
quais qui sont de plus en plus nombreux
à vivre avec leur pyramide un endroit
ils entreprennent dans des tas de
domaines ils agissent de manière plus
éthique plus solidaire plus
écoresponsable plein de projets secrets
dans tous les sens et d'ailleurs il
suffit d'écouter des ted
il suffit de voir dans des magazines
dans des livres tout ce qui est en train
de s'inventer tout cas créativité c'est
incroyable de voir cette créativité de
tous et kayakistes
alors est ce que tout ça sera suffisant
pour éviter une catastrophe écologique
ou social dans dix vingt ou trente ans
est ce que le barrage finira par
concéder complètement quels seront les
dégâts les états tomberont-ils en
faillite ou seront ils capable de se
réinventer
personne ne peut le dire mais puisque le
futur n'est pas écrit il ne sera
finalement que ce que nous nous sont
capables d'en faire collectivement alors
je ma conviction
pour conclure c'est que si nous sommes
suffisamment nombreux à remettre nos
pyramide à l'endroit a retrouvé notre
notre joie intérieure a retrouvé notre
sécurité intérieure à prendre notre
destin en mains à devenir plus
bienveillants envers nous-mêmes a osé
nous lancer dans un projet qui nous
tient à coeur
eh bien il ya peut-être une chance quand
même temps on puisse aussi rendre le
monde un peu meilleur
bonne navigation et tous
[Applaudissements]